Je suis le dieu de
[Musique]
Stunt One Piece a des combats vraiment géniaux,
nous essayons de capturer l'
esprit du manga et de vous offrir le
même
spectacle, nos acteurs ont vraiment relevé le
défi, personne n'est venu d'un point où je
pense que c'est le cas.  trop difficile parce qu'ils
veulent que ce soit aussi authentique que possible
pour leurs personnages individuels, ce sont
mes amis, vous ne pouvez pas les déranger,
vaincre étant ce personnage heureux et chanceux
utilisant sa capacité extensible à
se protéger ou à protéger ses amis
s'ouvre en quelque sorte  un monde où tout
est votre parc de jeu, donc nous concevons MVE pour
pouvoir y mettre l'élément amusant, il
bouge beaucoup, s'étire et
courbe son corps, oh mon Dieu, j'ai dû faire
beaucoup d'entraînement paralysant en tant que
voleur.  a beaucoup de choses sympas j'ai appris
à utiliser les fils il l'a pris comme un canard
dans l'eau et non, ce gamin peut voler je n'ai jamais
rien vécu de tel
j'espère que les fans verront la grande
attention portée aux détails en transformant zuro
en live
action mcken est  tout simplement incroyable en tant
qu'épéiste et a apporté beaucoup de son propre
style et de son expérience à ces combats,
il a le style à trois épées, deux épées
dans sa main, une dans sa bouche ah donc
c'est là que ça
se passe, je veux faire de mon mieux pour montrer ce que
Zoro  et je peux le
faire Nami est une pro du bâton d'arc, c'est
quelque chose que vous voyez dans le manga et
nous voulions en apporter plus dans la
série liveaction et mon Dieu, les
séquences de combat sont tellement amusantes à faire donc je suis un peu
comme les lancer toutes  dans Je vais les faire
tous, elle a l'air fantastique, je veux dire, le
cascadeur a été très impressionné, tout comme moi. En
fait, j'ai grandi en faisant du karaté, donc c'est une
chose vraiment amusante de pouvoir
refaire pour Usopp, nous avons eu une formation de tir de précision,
vous savez, je devais le faire.  apprends à
utiliser une
fronde, mais plus encore, les États-Unis passent une
grande partie de la saison à surmonter leurs peurs,
peut-être que je devrais y retourner pour m'assurer que
Mary est
sécurisée. Jacob est très drôle, il apporte une
énergie comme personne d'autre, il est comme un
chat effrayé mais il est  pas non plus parce que
quand il s'agit de ses amis, il est comme
d'accord, je suppose que je vais me
battre en jouant à Sanji, ma seule arme est mes
pieds, il n'utilise pas ses mains parce qu'il
doit les utiliser pour cuisiner, donc il
utilise exclusivement ses pieds, il l'
a définitivement  j'aimais donner des coups de pied aux gens à la tête et
donc nous nous entraînions à peu près 8 à 10
heures par jour et maintenant ma jambe peut passer complètement
au-dessus de ma tête et je donne un coup de hache, nous avons fait un
mélange de styles de coups de pied avec Sanji
parce que, étonnamment, dans leurs combats
avec juste  vos pieds sont difficiles à
garder
intéressants, alors ils voulaient comme des
influenceurs capoo, ils voulaient des
influenceurs de break dance et Taz était vraiment
dédié à ce métier et il a passé
des heures et des heures et des heures
à pratiquer un bon
combattant. Le travail acharné et le talent de ce groupe
ont amené ces personnages  à la vie
d'une manière à la fois familière et nouvelle,
ils sont tous phénoménaux et les voir
faire leurs propres cascades et se battre,
c'est l'une des parties les plus excitantes de
la
série. Je peux faire
[Musique]
plus d'
action live d'une seule pièce, c'est un
monde magnifique venu  à la vie impressionnant quand je
l'ai vu pour la première fois, j'étais tellement étonné que c'est
littéralement tout droit sorti du manga, les
décors sont énormes, tu te
dis oh mon Dieu, c'est réel, c'est le
plus grand spectacle en ce qui concerne la taille des
décors.  nombre de sets, nous allons sur des
sets différents à chaque épisode, nous étions en train
de construire un tout nouveau
monde, mais en honorant toujours la vision d'oda,
chaque détail devait être
pensé en un seul morceau, nous avons beaucoup de très
gros vaisseaux, ils sont réels, nous avons
les avons construits et je pense que cela donne de la
crédibilité à la mission mondiale
accomplie, ils devaient tous être très
spécifiques aux capitaines des navires,
montrons-leur à quoi ressemble la vraie terreur,
donc le canard missl Alvido est un
personnage terrifiant avec toute cette
idée de  son propre glamour donc le navire
devait ressembler à un véritable bateau pirate menaçant
mais rose et nous avons sculpté cette
tête de figure de canard géante, puis j'ai ajouté
des ailes de canard. Je nomme par la présente ce navire le go et
Mary the go et Mary est définitivement mon
ensemble préféré, c'est  la maison d'un chapeau de paille et
je suis le capitaine, donc c'est le meilleur navire
de tous les temps, la conception la plus difficile a été
de s'assurer que le mariage avait l'air
correct dans le manga, il y a ce genre de
tête de figure merveilleuse qu'il a,
mais si vous la construisiez réellement, elle
ressemblerait  dessin animé et il devait aussi être fidèle
au personnage de Luffy audacieux drôle
espiègle donc l'idée de créer la
figurine de Rire semblait parfaite dans
l'échelle et les détails, c'est
incroyable, tellement incroyable de pouvoir
tendre la main et toucher ces choses quoi de
neuf bartier mon préféré  L'ensemble est le
bartier sans conteste, Barer ressemble à une
destination glamour au milieu de
l'océan où les pirates venaient
manger. Ze a construit ce restaurant avec cette
magnifique grande salle à manger, toutes les
images encadrées en
arrière-plan étaient toutes d'une seule
pièce.  le monde les menus ont des plats en une seule pièce
le vin c'est en fait un vin en une seule
pièce que vous pouvez trouver dans la
mangue tout cela donne au monde une telle
richesse tu es le clown euh euh
Binky c'est vrai, la tente buggy buggy est tellement géniale que
tu te sens comme toi  Nous sommes dans ce
monde farfelu et déséquilibré. Je voulais que chaque décor soit
ancré dans la logique de l'histoire de One Piece,
alors j'ai pensé que la température de Buggy était
fabriquée à partir d'anciennes ventes de son navire, le chapiteau,
les deux poteaux sont en fait de vieux
mâts et les plates-formes d'acrobate sont
en fait.
Cress, tout était basé sur un navire, je n'ai
jamais vu une maison aussi grande auparavant,
impressionnant, les fans seront très
enthousiasmés par Kai's Mansion car l'
intérieur n'apparaît pas dans le manga,
vous voyez juste l'extérieur avec ce
jardin légèrement Allison Wonderland mais
ensuite le  l'intérieur il était basé sur l'
ensemble des histoires pour rester fidèle à l'
esprit du manga puis-je vous présenter Miss
Skai la Foy est pleine de
peintures trompe-l'œil de ces différents navires nous nous
déplaçons tous dans la salle à manger et la
salle à manger il y a ces milliers de
des assiettes partout sur les murs et au plafond, ce
qui donnait un merveilleux sentiment de grandeur,
c'est une mangue aimée par des millions de
personnes, ça a été un voyage incroyable
de travailler dessus et j'espère que les fans
l'aimeront autant que nous avons aimé la créer, c'est
parfait
[Musique]